hey everyone thanks so much for taking
the time to come listen to all of us
speak and really appreciate Sam and crew
having me over here today my my goal is
to talk a little bit about the early
decisions that can make or break a
company or sort of define the trajectory
of a company within a space so a little
bit more about me about six plus years
ago I started my first company I
actually joined you to me as a
co-founder it was the vision of two
Turkish immigrants who grew up in a
one-room schoolhouse in in southeastern
Turkey and I met them while they were on
their journey and got the opportunity to
help them build that company to to what
it is today and about halfway through
that time period I left and went and
spent six months at lift so really just
a passerby in that story but had the
opportunity to really learn why it was
successful and take those lessons and
then started spray how many people here
are familiar with Sprague fantastic for
those of you who aren't Spriggs mission
is to make it simple to eat well and our
basic belief is that you shouldn't have
to choose between quality and
convenience that you should be able to
push a button on your phone get a
healthy locally sourced amazing meal
delivered to you now within 15 minutes
on average in San Francisco and we just
raised around so that we can go and take
this vision to every place in the world
and hopefully hopefully end sort of the
the terrible choice that we face every
day right now in society which is am I
going to work hard for my food or I'm
going to eat crap and spring hopes to
change that so one of my my goals here
is to talk a little bit about the
detailed like this
civic decisions that we made really
early on at udemy and sprague that made
them successful because if you think
about it both udemy and Sprague are an
extremely crowded or competitive markets
I mean they're big markets education and
food and so as a result there were a lot
of really early strategic decisions that
most people didn't really understand at
the time right so we had a lot of
trouble raising money at both companies
both that you to me and at Sprague
because investors didn't understand why
these strategic decisions we made at
udemy were going to be impactful and so
what I want to do here is just provide a
little bit of a lens for how we made
those decisions why we made them and
I'll leave the outcomes up to you to
decide so I don't feel like it's totally
appropriate and some of them information
is confidential
about whether or not these decisions
worked out but they certainly did shape
the companies as they are today
and so I think like the most important
thing to realize is that all of these
companies started with a very clear
vision and I remember like I asked
getting asked this question I get this
ask ask this question about both udemy
and Sprague and lyft too frankly and
it's and the questions you know what
were you thinking when you first started
the company like how is it changed
what's different and I've realized now
that the answers always has always been
at least for my companies that the
vision has never changed and that really
we've gotten better at explaining the
vision and perhaps we've better define
the details of how that vision will come
to life but the original vision of udemy
was always to make possible for anyone
to learn anything they wanted and that's
something that has always been constant
and drove a lot of the original
decisions on the strategic decisions
that we made and so the major strategic
decisions there are three of them that
we made at udemy that today some of them
may seem obvious and some of them don't
seem obvious and remember that's
important one of the most common things
about these early strategic decisions is
that they always look like hindsight's
20/20 they always look kind of obvious
to 20 years later but you're gonna be in
a situation in the future if you're
starting a business or you're joining a
company which is actually equally as
hard to do successfully that where
you're going to have to make these
strategic decisions when it's not
obvious so that in ten years as it is
and the three ones at udemy were you
know whether or not we should be live or
recorded paid versus free open versus
closed I'll talk about them in more
detail so at you to me one of the
initial things that was super
interesting was as I mentioned I joined
the company in fact the company had over
a hundred thousand lines of code and was
around for about three plus years in
some format or the other in sort of
Turkey actually before I ever got my
hands on the product and got an
opportunity to work on the company and
so by nature that my co-founders who
were both engineers had built this or
about that point they had built this
beautiful live education platform it was
at the time and I think maybe even to
this day the most robust live online
education platform in existence it was
completely flash based which at the time
was of course a really smart decision um
it's since been killed by Apple in some
ways but I was flash-based it could
support multiple video cameras it had a
beautiful whiteboard and a presentation
and it has an extensible infrastructure
for applications on top of it and so
this was an incredible effort imagine
these two two guys from Turkey who have
been slaving away for three years
building a live education platform and I
went and tried to sell this platform
because that was my job I was the
business co-founder who would talk to
customers and sell it and I spent months
and months and months trying to sell
instructors on coming on the platform
and teaching courses on udemy and this
is the first lesson of any successful
company which is that the only way to
really know whether or not your idea
works is to interview in pitch customers
I tend to do it in two ways either one
I'm discovering information by
interviewing customers or two i'm
actually literally just pitching
customers and trying to get me to use my
product and getting some level of early
traction and
witnessing people and trying to use some
sort of soft skills to figure out
whether or not what they're doing is
right and so one of the big early
decisions that I made was and I said
this hundreds of times before we ever
did it but it was like I want you to
kill the live platform like it's only
gonna be recorded and at the time there
were dozens of online education
companies and not a single one of them
believed that recorded was going to be
the future and the reason why I had that
insight was because I said hey nobody's
teaching on these live courses like I
could not get traction on live courses
and so I begged my co-founders and
actually they agreed to be honest so it
was one of those things where it's just
like you know prioritizing on the
product roadmap to build a lot an
offline component sort of an
asynchronous component where you could
post videos on you to me we ended up
making the decision to post videos and I
was able to get traction on a couple
early video courses and that defined the
company in a lot of ways from
asynchronous live online education
marketplace which clearly didn't work to
an asynchronous video marketplace which
is one of the biggest early decisions we
made that was fairly painful at the time
and then the second thing that we had to
decide was whether or not to go paid
versus free yeah was to go paid versus
free and this was a really tough
decision and even today if you look at
companies like Coke Adam E or Coursera
or Udacity or Khan Academy there are
dozens of online education providers
that have decided to go completely free
and so I want to tie this back to the
mission again the mission of udemy was
always to make education open and
accessible and I think it was very very
easy for the press and for sort of the
emotions of decision makers involved in
this to say if education is going to be
open and accessible it should be free
and at udemy we decided to charge for
courses and we decided to enable
charging and the reason was because we
felt like we understood the marketplace
better than anyone else and our view was
that actually if our goal was to make
education open and accessible the only
way to do that would be if instructors
were going to make money and so our view
it wasn't paid
for selfish reasons so that we could
make money it was paid because that was
the only way to increase the library of
courses that we had at udemy and by
dramatically increasing the library
courses we were increasing the amount
available to consumers to learn from and
so today udemy has you know tens of
thousands of courses on the platform
it's probably the largest online course
marketplace on the Internet
certainly one of the most successful
financially and that was a large part of
the fact that we decided to go paid
mostly because of the same reason why
the condom at academy was free like our
view is five-minute videos on YouTube
were not actually teaching people a
whole lot but for 10 our core you know
four to ten hour courses online with a
small financial cost would actually be
better for people and so we ended up
making that decision and it was huge for
the company and then the final thing is
open versus closed and so another thing
about the Khan Academy or Coursera
Udacity was this idea that like only
only edge only elite professors or
educators could be good at teaching
online and you know one of the big
decisions that unity very early on was
how close do you make an education
marketplace right certainly if you're
you know eBay or oDesk or Kickstarter
you're gonna have different views on
open or closed and it's important to
recognize that actually every
marketplace needs to take a different
stance based on its specific market that
it's in and our insight in education was
hey actually in education if you are
more open than you're more likely to
attract the unexpected teacher in you
know in in Barcelona who happens to be
an incredible web development instructor
but doesn't have a PhD in education or
doesn't have a PhD in computer science
and so again it was an example of where
I think it was so easy and obvious to
say like only elite professors could be
competent in in the protein you know
online and that's what a lot of other
our counterparts took and by making it
open these strategic decisions had an
outsized impact on our scale
because now we're able to serve so many
more so much more diversity to our
customer base and so I think like in
summary it's it's not necessarily the
case that it's obvious even today
whether those strategic decisions will
bear out I mean udemy's on year five
it's got you know billion-dollar
companies usually take seven to ten plus
years to to really reach fruition and
but I think that today we're at least
from what I know almost certainly one of
the strongest players in the marketplace
in online education and the main reason
for that was making decisions based on
this idea of hey how do I deliver upon
my mission in the most productive manner
and I think that's really powerful now
the next thing is sprig and I'll talk a
little bit about sprig sprigs mission
was to enable anyone to get a hot
healthy meal at the touch of a button
and really what it was it was just about
making access to sort of quality meals
available to anyone anyone on the planet
and this was particularly interesting
because it wasn't that long ago and the
and the the sort of war is still raging
on I think like one of the interesting
things about Sprague is that and the
same thing is somewhat true for you to
me but I think it's much more true for
spraying businesses are about customers
like consumer businesses if you're
working in a consumer business and SAS
business to frankly b2b business to but
if you're in a consumer business the
customer wins it's a democracy like at
the end of the day the company that's
going to be the most successful company
in a given space is going to be voted on
by the people who actually buy from that
customer base from that from that
product the reason why that's important
is because I feel like so many ontraport
for entrepreneurs and lots of second
tier investors today are always looking
for the easy way out what's the business
that's gonna make me the most money
tomorrow what's the business that sort
of like provides a good unit economics
and so I'm gonna pay $10 today for a
user I'm gonna get $12 back in six
months
and I'm gonna make money off of that
user forever right and the problem with
that is
markets don't play out over six to 12
months and if you take a snapshot of any
one business at one period of time over
the course of ten years it may look
really really attractive on the inside
but consumers decide whether or not
businesses are successful and so I think
that's a completely perverse way of
looking at businesses uber is not
amazing because uber said hey like you
know we're gonna be a distributed
marketplace that has this beautiful sort
of like twenty percent take between
supply and demand
uber was successful because they did
whatever it took to deliver the customer
a car within five minutes or three
minutes now because they believe that
that was what was going to make
customers the most value and so in every
space there's some really really hard
thing that you have to do and take on as
a founder in order to achieve the
long-term results that you want
and so at Sprague we had three very
difficult things that we decided to take
on that nobody else that almost nobody
else took on all three of these things
and I think that's one of the like
interesting lessons so the first part of
this is eliminating friction so our view
at you at Sprague is that when it's a
daily recurring habit something like
food that the easier it is to transact
in that in that or in that product
they're sorry in that market the more
likely you are to win and the best
example is McDonald it's right
McDonald's the most convenient meal on
the planet also the most successful food
franchise in the history of America and
our vision was that friction was hot was
the most important thing now you look at
the food space today and everybody else
has decided to go against that
why do door - and post mates have
couriers that pick up from restaurants
there's two reasons
one obviously breath I mean there are
many reasons and there's many valid
reasons for this isn't it denigrate
another competitor it's really just to
show you what my philosophy is my
philosophy is that just because it's an
easier business model to have
restaurants make the food
and it's an easier business model to
have 1099 contract workers go and pick
up the food from one place and drop it
off to another so you can wipe your
hands clean of the trend clean up the
transaction that's not what matters it
does not matter whether or not your
business looks pretty on the inside what
matters is whether or not consumers
really love your product and whether or
not you're delivering the product that
ten years from now is going to dominate
the market so we take on a ton of pain
like spring is by far one of the hardest
businesses to run in the on-demand
economy space right we build we make all
of our own food we have to control the
entire supply chain from the time it
comes to the farms from the time it
grows on the farms to the time it gets
the customers door and then we have to
figure out how to deliver that food to
you in fifteen minutes
hot and you know that's the pain we
decided to take on because when I look
at the food space I say what's gonna
happen in ten years in ten years
nobody's gonna push a button and wait 45
minutes to an hour and a half to get
food from a restaurant down the street
that's putting a ton of
butter in their food and oil so that you
eat it and are addicted to it that's
just not the future and so one of the
things we believe in at sprague is we
will take on the pain so that you have a
great experience right and I think
that's one of the examples of something
that that I really get frustrated with
when I meet people who are building
companies were always like well the
margins are so great I'm like the
margins like like what are what are we
trying to do here are we trying to build
a business that's gonna sell you know
fit ten million dollars in revenue and
and make eighty percent EBIT da like
that's not interesting to me like my
goal as an entrepreneur is to change the
world and to be a iconic and build a
tonic companies and that requires doing
the hard work and the hard work that
Amazon and Google and uber did I think
are great examples do you take I already
talked to doober I'll talk about Amazon
everyone else in the e-commerce space
when Amazon was starting out was saying
was trying to do a distributed model
almost everyone what I think Amazon and
bazo's recognized was that
five to ten years from now you're the
customer is going to be able to order
something on the internet that comes to
them in two days and now they're looking
at one hour right and so Amazon went
through the absolutely batshit crazy
idea at the time that they were gonna
build warehouses all over the country
and house like hundreds of millions of
dollars worth of inventory now probably
billions of dollars worth of inventory
in these warehouses and then they're
going to actually like ship real product
to customers like at the time this was
an insane proposition today like B's
o--'s and Amazon are much larger than
any other company and kicked eBay's ass
and frankly which was the only other
company that got to that level of scale
in this space because they said we're
gonna do the hard work and we're gonna
make this make this business work and
we're gonna deliver customer the optimum
ultimate value Google the same way right
every search engine was saying well we
can't figure out how to make search work
so we're just gonna give you a directory
and Google said no like actually it's
really really important to make search
as easy as possible and even though the
algorithms are hard and are gonna
require building our own data centers
and our own BOTS that scrape the
internet like we'll do the work and so
that's that's one thing and the second
thing is having a position on what type
of what type of product and what you're
gonna stand for so it's sprague one of
the things we do is we source all of our
own ingredients people don't often know
this we don't do a great job of telling
the story yet but we actually source all
organic produce and all of our meats are
sustainably raised free-range
hormone-free antibiotic-free and we
personally know most of the farms from
which we source and the reason for this
is that we believe in five to ten years
people are going to get far more
educated about food and are gonna care a
lot more about what they eat and realize
that the addiction we have to sugar in
America is counter is is just as bad as
an addiction to cigarettes or cocaine
and so as a result we made a long-term
badatz break that today I think a lot of
investors are like do people really care
about this do people really care about
health and wellness to people in the
Middle America really care about this
and we took a very different approach
and said actually we think even if not
everyone cares about it today they'll
care about it in five to ten years and
we're gonna ride that wave and be on the
forefront of that this is a bet you know
I don't know if it'll work out but it's
something that we're making I think in
large part because we are customer
driven and thinking about what the
customer wants and then the final thing
I think is that you really can't know
some things without actually doing the
business so when we first started
Sprague the idea was to build a
marketplace for for food our idea was
you should be able to open your phone
and order a chef from the personal chef
down the street or from your neighbor
who cooks really good food really good
Thai food right or or the Jewish family
three blocks down who's got an amazing
recipe for four matzo ball soup but a
lot of people would have taken that
vision and sort of because of their ego
associated with how focused they were on
their vision and their view of the
market and would have just charged
forward and you see lots of companies
and lots of founders who are incredibly
ego driven about how they make decisions
and so they don't really listen when
they're in the marketplace and so what
we do I think a Sprague that we've done
quite well is actually we look at this
and say oh you just heard me say I
wasn't sure if the organic bat was gonna
work like there are very few founders
out there who will say that publicly and
that's ridiculous
the best founders and the things that
I've learned at least in my career is
that the best founders have no ego and
so whereas we thought it was going to be
a marketplace and we started executing
on it
we started executing on a marketplace we
started working with many different
chefs and pretty clear pretty quickly by
serving chefs food from all different
places around the around San Francisco
we realized that most chefs are really
really bad and that it's not a
profession where the like 90% are better
than the 10% which is the exact opposite
of udemy by the way in our opinion right
in our opinion you know me leveraging
the 90% was the best way to surface the
best content because
there's no real cost to having an
additional online course but at Sprague
right if we serve you bad food you're
not going to come back and so as a
result we actually ended up switching
from a marketplace to a consolidated
model where we make all the food again
owning a kitchen building out the supply
chain dealing with all the hassles of
making real food and managing a hundred
person sort of culinary team in about
sixty right now I guess and I think that
was another key strategic decision that
we made that sort of really informed
what Sprague was about so I guess my
point is that overall when you look at
companies in the early days you'd be
shocked by how much these core strategic
decisions define the potential success
of a company and I would recommend a to
make sure that you're always questioning
those strategic decisions in case
someone else in the market proves that
you're wrong and actually like their
their ideas better than yours and then
just go ruthlessly copy them and then on
the flip side in the event that you are
right and focus on this that it could
dramatically allow you and you you have
to be patient with some of those bets
because over time you'll see that those
bets will will lead to outside there's
out sized results so that's sort of a
little bit of the story of udemy and
Sprague and I want to open it up for
questions
come on down for questions hi you talked
about having a very clear vision at the
outset and that hasn't really changed
over time and yet you also talked about
how you're very open to changing tactics
so have you come across situations where
you're V initial vision has changed and
and and how anyway what was the trigger
for that if that's the case yes so I
think it's important to recognize that
the original mission statement or vision
of a company is tend to tends to be
really really broad and so it's the type
of thing that's hard to change right
like like wanting everyone to be able to
have access to healthy food it's sort of
the type of thing that could have a
hundred different variations to it and
so actually like I think the point of
that statement was that you know no
actually like at udemy and Sprague we've
never changed what we've been trying to
do we've just changed how we're gonna do
it and we're so maniacally focused on
the vision actually or the mission that
we don't care about how we get there and
that's actually what's most important is
that the process by which you get to the
end result is far less important than
the end result itself and so if you
guide yourself by the end result you're
much more likely to succeed and find the
right product because you're most likely
wrong about the first product you come
up with hi I was hoping you could talk a
little bit you talked about the supply
chain for the food what about the
logistics of delivery and you know
making sure it arrives hot do you feel
like you've taken any shortcuts there
because I just rigged all the time and
it's always there very quickly and I
don't know how you do it
it's really hard so there's really two
things that Sprague does that's unique
the first thing is that we have a
culinary science team that basically
tries to figure out how to deliver food
well okay so delivering food is a
difficult challenge
because there's all these factors that
you have no control over right
traditionally food is made to be served
right after it's made and served on your
plate and the delivery method whether
it's the fact that you have a third
party in between the chef and the and
the customer whether it's the fact that
you're going through a car is a
difficult process and so we focus really
hard on that we test every meal that we
make in advance to see whether it
delivers well and even then I'm sure if
you're a spread customer you know we
missed some times and so we're
constantly focused on that the second
thing is how we deliver the 15 minute
SLA and what we do is we build a
real-time system that can deal with
routing and in returning management in
real time and again like if you compare
us to our competitors in the space
nobody is building a real-time system
that's at the level of complexity of
Sprigg in simultaneously mate trying to
figure out how to make food that
actually delivers well in fact you'll
almost hear nobody talking about these
problems as problems that they're
dealing with and that's kind of the
point right so how does Sprague deliver
so quickly it's because we have an a
team of you know eight engineers to PhD
data scientists who focus all their time
on the real-time algorithm that makes
sure you get your food quickly and every
time we screw it up we beat ourselves up
like crazy about it and people go around
the office like depressed it honestly
feels like a lot of times that Sprague
that were not like on track to become a
billion dollar company we're actually
gonna fail the next day because people
take it so personally and they're so
focused and so hard on themselves on
actually delivering the customer the
best value that we like we we hate it
when you don't have a great experience
and as a result like you see that in the
outcomes which is that actually today
it's very very rare to get a delivery
time over thirty five minutes minutes
you know a few percentage points oh
sorry the yeah we I mean we use contract
delivery delivery folks as well as other
on-demand services and so we pay them on
a per delivery basis so they make and
that's one of the reasons why it matters
to be so quick because they make more if
they deliver if they're able to deliver
more meals hey great
so I've been recently become interested
in this idea of the Eagle list
entrepreneur who finds a mission that's
greater themselves and it's no longer
should I do this or should I do that
it's what furthers the mission and I
read a bit bit about Elon Musk who one
of the reasons why employees respect him
is because he has a picture of Mars and
then picture right next to Mars
terraform but he has no pictures of
himself and his offices and so when you
are egoless as an entrepreneur and you
draw from sources like the customer or
the business or what's best for business
or what's best for the customer it seems
like your greatest source is a customer
can you relay a specific story where you
found the customer wanted something just
the kind of like job said well if you
deliver what the customer wanted you
would have given a course or something
what was when you backtracked against
that and you went against what the
customers were saying in the market yeah
I mean almost all this receive decisions
I talked about just now like if you take
the live versus recorded one I mean most
people would ask you that they would
prefer a live online education to record
an online education so the reality is
taking your ego out of it is not about
being submissive to the customer it's
merely about listening and not letting
your own like self-worth be tied to the
idea you have so I don't think being
egoless is about like oh like it's not
about being selfless right that's
different I mean I have that value too
but that's not the important value for
an entrepreneur the important value for
an entrepreneur is to realize that
decisions are extremely challenging and
that every decision you make is fairly
important and so you should be willing
to change and backtrack on those
decisions if they turn out not to be
moving in the right direction and the
quicker and more efficiently you make
decisions and then
change decisions when they're wrong the
better off you are achieving long-term
results I was actually kind of curious
if you've looked at automation for sprig
and where you think that may go into the
future with drone delivery robotic chefs
other things along those lines yeah I
mean our mission is to make it simpler
to eat well right so drones make it
simpler to deliver you food one day that
may happen I think it's very clearly
farther away than everyone thinks I mean
VR and drones are the new hot thing that
everyone's talking about you know there
was a time when we were all talking
about flying cars I mean there is a very
reasonable possibility that this becomes
real but I try to focus more on five to
ten years out and wait for the science
to catch up with reality there and so if
it happens like we will immediately go
and try to figure out how but I think
that's you know it's it's much further
away than people realize at least that's
my perspective for now hey thanks
everyone